the david pakman show subreddit is a
place where more than 14,000 of our
viewers and listeners are regularly
participating in respectful and
substantive political discussions you
can find that at david pakman.com slash
read it a few posts from today that I
want to call to your attention a user
named the goat of goats 999 says what's
wrong with a public option don't most
countries with universal health care
also allow private insurance so this is
a very reasonable question and there's a
couple things that are being mixed here
if you have universal health care it
doesn't necessarily follow that you make
private insurance illegal in fact I
don't think that should be a priority
let private insurance exist if the
nationalized the universal health care
system medicare for all or whatever else
is good enough people are going to
prefer it over private insurance and
this will naturally as the free
marketers like to say it will naturally
do what needs to happen to private
insurance a public option is something
else and studies have shown that public
options would only lower premiums by
about seven to eight percent which is
marginal when it comes to the total lack
of affordability of health insurance for
so many people in this country so I
think it's important to distinguish that
a public option is something that can
exist without having any kind of
universal health care or in addition to
and it is a separate question from
whether private for-profit insurance
should be allowed to exist even if
something like Medicare for all is put
in place I happen to think the answer is
yes let it exist don't go through the
hassle of saying we are going to make
your business illegal things will just
sort themselves out if medicare for all
or whatever government program is put in
place is good enough and people will
decide what it is that they prefer
another post from user Ryan Lynne Berg
Oh about New Mexico rolling out a plan
for tuition Free State College I don't
we don't need to analyze the proposal
specifically but I think that on both
single-payer health care and tuition and
dealing with homelessness I am very much
in favor of states piloting programs on
there
you will often hear a talking point from
the right on all of these social program
proposals health care whatever the case
is that it would not work in the United
States it works in small European
countries because they are small and
sometimes they say that it works because
the countries are homogeneous although
it doesn't make any sense with regard to
a lot of these programs a story for a
different day I think it would be great
for states to pilot some of these
programs there are many US states with
higher populations and larger land
masses than many European countries and
they would serve as great proving
grounds unfortunately Vermont
single-payer attempt did not end up
happening but I would love to see New
Mexico do tuition free college I would
love for any state to show the viability
of these programs and also the economic
benefits that they would bring with them
a user on the subreddit named hollow
brine found the david pakman show on tic
toc yeah so listen we I like to sample
different platforms because you never
know what could be the next Instagram or
the next big thing and we've tried
things out on the show that don't go
anywhere and that's okay we just stopped
them and then we try something else and
then some of the things we try work
really well YouTube being one example
the show Instagram page being another
example so after reading a lot about
this new platform called tick-tock we
created a David Pakman show account
there we've only posted one video so far
we've only got like five followers there
so far but I actually think there could
be something to this platform and I like
to try to be an early adopter of a lot
of these things so find us on tik-tok
send me ideas about what we should even
be doing there we're just learning about
the platform and figuring it out
join the david pakman show subreddit at
david pakman.com slash re d di t more
than 14,000 of you already have and a
great source of political discussion
respectful debate story ideas for the
show look forward to seeing you there